Paradise regained, um, except well
as anyone who's read and maybe there's
someone here in this room who has read
the continuation of the novel,
Gone With the wind as anyone
who has read that knows,
or is anyone who's seen let's say the
bride of Chucky or fast and furious part
three nos.
Um,
sequels are rarely greater
than the original works,
whose stories they,
whose stories they continue.
And it's almost as if the diminished
appeal where something like an inevitable
and necessary fact of the sequel.
It just comes attached to the notion
of the SQL. And I think that the,
that the disappointment aroused by SQL
SQL of any kind is a phenomenon about
which Milton John Milton as he wrote
paradise regained, must've been, um,
extremely aware. So, so
it's Thomas Elwood, um,
that was one of the young men who
acted as a secretary for Milton.
Um,
it was Thomas Elwood who claimed a years
after the poet's death that he had been
responsible for Milton's having
written the sequel to paradise lost.
He recorded having told Milton,
um, after he had read it,
an early manuscript copy of paradise lost.
This is before paradise lost was even,
uh, in print. He, he, he,
he reports to us having told Milton,
thou hast said much here of paradise lost,
but what has thou to
say of Paradise found?
And then Elwood continues and it's,
it's a wonderful little bit of a,
it's a wonderful little
bit of information.
Milton made no answer to me but
sat sometime and amuse and I,
I like a lot of,
like a lot of critics of Milton.
I have a hard time believing that it
was Elwood squirmy little Elwood who
planted the idea of a
sequel to paradise lost in,
in Milton's head.
But I think it's nonetheless interesting
that this story has been so widely
circulated and it's almost
invariably cited by scholars of,
of paradise regained because
I think in some way, uh,
readers are looking for some excuse
really for Milton's having written it.
Paradise lost seems in itself,
so absolutely complete and so magnificent.
The idea that it requires this
equal, um, is, is one that is,
uh, it seems suspicious or questionable
too. A lot of Milton's readers now,
Milton's, oh nephew, Edward Phillips
described the way in which readers,
even in Milton's lifetime judge
the sequel to be the, the, the,
the inferior,
the lesser of the two works.
And so Philip tells us in his biography,
and this is actually usefully included
in the back of the the Hughes Edition,
a Phillips tells us,
um,
that paradise regained is generally in
censured to be much inferior to the other.
The Milton could not hear with patients
any such thing when related to him.
And I love this image of the old man
impatient with any comment that might be a
little, the accomplishment of the, of the
sequel sequel. And I think it's a, it's a,
it's a moving, it's a moving
image and if Milton's nephew is,
is right here as I suspect he is,
then I think it's worth pursuing the
reason for which Milton might have
considered paradise,
regained the sequel to be the greater
work or a work in some way more
sophisticated and more
advanced than paradise lost.
And I think in a lot of ways
it is, it is exactly that. Now,
surely one of the first things
that we noticed when we,
when we read the sequel
to paradise lost is,
is really the radical radical
difference of its style.
The literary style or what we can
think of as the verbal texture of,
of paradise regained really constitutes
one of its greatest departures and
obviously one of its most deliberate
departures from the first step.
And all those,
most readers of regained find it's
less stylistically pleasing them.
Lost. Uh, Milton has, has embraced this
style, I think for an important reason.
He has very consciously imposed a set
of constraints on his verbal style,
a set of constraints on his
entire poetic imagination and our,
our appreciation of the beauty and
the meaning of this poem is actually,
I think inextricable for our
understanding of this poem. Um,
understanding of the, the, the, the,
the severity of the lesson that
this poem has to teach us. Um,
this poet, and we know this because we've
spent a lot of time with John Milton.
Now, this poet was instinctively
given to verbal excess, uh,
to an almost unimaginable degree and he
clearly had to struggle hard to reign in
a lot of his most powerful
literary impulses in order
to produce a work such as
paradise regained to work of such
seemingly charmless severity.
Um,
this poem has been scrubbed clean of,
of verbal and images stick extravagance.
I'm scrubbed cleaner even than the last
two books of paradise lost, which were,
which were themselves,
um, radical departures.
And I think in a lot of
ways paradise regained,
resembles a stylistically in
terms of it's verbal texture.
The last books of paradise lost.
Now Milton has purge this poem as
well of the Grammatical Obscurity,
the syntactical obscurity that
we found in paradise lost.
And you remember all of those ambiguities
syntactical ambiguity's that we're
always opening up far more signifying
possibilities that we could even begin to
deal with.
Milton has clipped so many of those long
and wandering sentences into short and
unequivocal declarations and
he's replaced the lushness of,
of so many of those similes and literary
ornaments with what we can think of is
the puritan austerity of,
of simple argument and
simple statement of fact.
And this poem has been written
and what is often described,
um, now as the periods plain style, uh,
something like the conversational
style of unambiguous,
straightforward language
that was supposedly favored
by the Puritan clergy in
the, in the 17th century.
And I think that makes sense.
This poem has been written in what
we can think of as the plain style,
but if that's the case,
how strange and how
surprising that this poem,
which is written in a poetic language
as plain and unambiguous as anything
Milton ever put on paper,
how unbelievably odd it is that this poem
paints for us a world in which so few
statements can actually be understood.
Um, all of the, all of the,
all of the characters in paradise
regained. And I'm including,
there aren't that many of them, but I'm
including of course the son of God. Um,
all of the characters fail at sometime
or another to understand even the
clearest,
even the most perspicuous language,
a much like Adam in books 11 and 12 of
paradise lost the characters in Paris,
right? Gained or on some level
profoundly, uh, clueless.
And, and their cognitive incapacity,
which, which actually comes in a,
in a variety of shapes depending
where you are in the poem there.
Cognitive incapacity usually involves
their inability to, to interpret fully,
um,
and to interpret accurately,
accurately a statement or a text statement
or a text that in our estimation,
um, seems to be just about as clear and
unambiguous as it could possibly be.
Now,
one of the texts that proves so puzzling
to the characters of paradise regained
is also a puzzle to Adam in paradise lost.
And so I want to look back at the ending
of paradise lost in order to see a way
in which that poem had been
preparing us all along for,
for the sequel.
I,
um,
I think you'll remember our are
mentioning in class that odd and sometimes
irritating way in which,
which Adam was always jumping the
gun in his interpretation of, of,
of future Christian history.
The,
in the lesson that that Micah was
presenting him and one of the central
historical documents that Adam seemed
particularly predisposed to misinterpret
was what is known as the Prodo Evangelian
and that's been spelled for you.
Piaroti oh, eva. N. G. E. L. I. U. M.
That's been spelled for you on your
handout. So you don't need my um,
orthography right now. And, and, and,
and the protege evangelism,
which is the Greek for first gospel or
the first good news is one of the ways in
which Christians refer
to genesis 14 and 15.
It's the prophecy from the book of Genesis
that God delivers to the serpent God
prophesies that the serpents
eventual punishment.
And this is on the
handout that the serpent,
eventually we will be punished and I will
put enmity between thee and the woman.
And between thy seed and her seed,
it shall bruise thy head and
thou shalt bruise his heel.
Now, this is the anticipation of the end
as, as presented, as imagined in genesis.
And it's, it's this text that
the new testament uses, um,
to forge a connection
between the story of Christ,
which is obviously the new
testament story and the, the, the,
the first initial texts in the tradition,
which is the,
the story of Adam and eve. And so
for Christians, Christ of course,
is the woman's seed, the
great, great, great, great,
great, great grandson of, uh,
of Adam and eve.
And he will one day bruise the head
of the serpent who is interpreted by
Christians to be Satan, um,
even as Satan will be dogging,
um, his steps. Now,
the text of this prophecy
is reproduced and reworked,
I think almost to a compulsive
degree in paradise. Lost, um, uh,
allusions to the prophecy
in genesis agenda,
the pro to Evangelian appear foe in five
separate places in the last books of
Milton's, APEC and a, and an a,
an actually in far more places
than that in paradise regained.
This prophecy is a text that
has to be read and interpreted.
It's mold over and reinterpreted and
it's Michael's task in the last books of
paradise lost to teach
Adam how to read it.
Adam has to figure out,
and this actually and
itself requires a lot of,
of toodle edge on Michael's part.
Adam has to figure out that
the serpent is actually Satan.
That's nothing that comes
instinctively or intuitively to Adam.
And that of course the seed is the Messiah
who Adam will eventually interpret to
be the son of God.
And so let's look at the end of paradise
lost here because Michael is not only
teaching Adam how to, how to
understand the Proto Proto Evangelian,
but he's teaching us also,
I think preparing us to
read paradise regained.
So this is, um, page
four 63 and the Hughes,
it's book 10 of actually,
I'll be, um, I'll,
I'm going to be skipping around the,
the first passage that we'll be looking
at his book. 10 line one 79, um,
that's when the sun delivers
the prophecy to the serpent. Um,
and then at line 500 of book 10,
we see Satan trying to figure out what
the Sun could possibly have meant.
Book 11, line one 15 if you can
flip through pages fast enough. Um,
God himself explains to Michael in
heaven about the prophecy of the seed.
And then Michael due to flee relays this
message to Adam himself in book 12 line
one 50. Now, there's obviously an
excessive proliferation here of,
of prophetic statements so excessive
that you probably weren't able to flip
through your books nearly quickly enough.
And,
and it's no wonder that Adam is really
beside himself with such an eager desire
to get to get to the end.
I'm so obsessive.
Lee Is this prophecy of the end.
Uh,
presented it at the end of paradise lost.
Adam has learned about the birth of Jesus.
He's learned about the Messiah who
will actually be born of a woman, uh,
called the woman's seed
in the book of Genesis.
And he thinks he has this prophecy
of the seed completely figured out.
He thinks he understands now how the story
of Christian history is going to end.
So this is, um, lined
three 75 of, of book 12,
line three, 75 of book 12.
Um, at the top of page four,
63 Oh, profit of glad tidings, Adam says,
finisher of utmost hope.
Now clear.
I understand what oft
my steady his thoughts.
I've searched in vain why our great
expectation should be called the seed of
woman. And of course, and we,
and we're used to this because we read
the last two books of paradise lost.
Adam is wrong to think that he has a
clear understanding of what his Greg, uh,
of the great expectations of the end.
And he imagines once again with a kind
of singularly dull witted literalism just
how this prophecy of the seed is going
to play out. So at line three 83,
Adam says, needs, must the serpent.
Now his capital brews expect with
mortal pain and a capital bruises,
literally a bruise to the head
say where and when their fight,
what stroke shall bruise the
victors heal. And Adam, of course,
has utterly imagined or imagine
precisely the wrong kind of ending.
This isn't going to be a physical fight,
who's victory can be pinned down to some
specific time and specific place, uh, uh,
kind of a terrifying event for which
tickets can be purchased. And, and,
and, and, and, and,
and Michael recognizes Adams
interpretation as a misinterpretation.
And so he, he corrects it.
And at line three 86, uh,
Michael Tells Adam this dream not of
their fight as of a duel or the local
wounds of head,
or he'll,
we're not supposed to imagine some
gunslinger show down at the end of time
between the Messiah and the serpent.
And remember that Milton Milton,
Adam is still imagining the
serpent being a serpent.
He hasn't yet figured out
that the serpent is Satan.
We're not going to have an actual war
capable of producing actual wounds.
And Adam of course,
in his defense,
and I think he does need a little
defending here, um, has in mind the story,
the war in heaven, the story of an
actual fight full of local wounds,
um, that, that all to local wounds,
they were healed instantly that Raefiel
had conveyed to him of course in book
six and which David Carrell had
a wonderfully explicated, um,
for our benefit.
But the battle that will turn out to
reconfigure all of Christian history isn't
going to proceed along the
vulgarly literal line set
forth in the war in heaven.
Um,
it's as if Michael is trying to tell
Adam to forget to forget everything that
it,
Raphael told him to forget
that monumental a war that,
that Raphael had had relayed because
that kind of thing simply isn't going to
happen anymore.
The fight between the fight between
Satan and the seed of the serpent and the
seed is going to be a much
subtler one. And, and,
and the Messiah will begin his destruction
of the serpent by becoming a man
himself. Uh, just just like Adam had,
had become a man at his, at his birth.
That seems to be pretty much the gist of,
of Michael's theology and paradise lost.
Well,
so Milton finishes paradise lost.
Evidently he begins Paradise regained
even before paradise lost has,
has found its way into print and paradise
regained his published four years
later in 1671 and paradise paradise
regained his published four years later.
And it's all about that redemption,
that regaining of paradise that Michael
had prophesied at the end of paradise
lost. And as you can tell
from the title of the Sequel,
Paradise regained is all about
returning and, and, and, and repetition.
And we shouldn't think that the same.
The SQL here is simply repeating
and elaborating on the ideal,
on the ideas with which the
original poem had concluded. Um,
now what's true,
the paradise regained does repeat the
Prodo Evangelian that prophecy that the
sun,
the sun's destruction of the serpent
that we finally figured out is actually
Satan and approves just as obsessively
interested in that bizarre prophecy as
paradise lost was.
But this new poem repeats that
prophecy with a difference.
And I think there are all sorts of
ways in which the, the, the poem is,
is exploring and we exploring a lot
of the implications and a lot of the
consequences of the
very idea of repetition,
implicit or compacted in that
prefix re of paradise regained.
Um,
this is a work devoted to how the lost
paradise will eventually become the
regained paradise. And, and obviously for,
for Christians or Orthodox
Christians have almost, almost any,
any stripe,
um,
that regaining that redemption
will hinge on the atonement on the,
on the moment of the
crucifixion. Well, um,
that's pretty much out of
the question for Milton.
So we have to ask the question.
Um,
how does Milton account for that pivotal
moment in Christian history that the
turning point from the old covenant
with God to the new covenant,
how does Milton Imagine the shift from
Paradise lost to paradise regained and
the, and the answer as we have come, uh,
as we have come to recognize,
because if these are the kinds of the
answers that we get when we ask questions
about Milton,
the answer is as shocking one.
Milton quite simply doesn't mention,
and this is unspeakably sublime,
he just doesn't bother to mention
the crucifixion in paradise regained.
Um,
and and of,
of course we already know that the subject
of the crucifixion is one that Milton
has long had an awkward relation to.
Um,
he wasn't able to finish that early
poem with a passion, um, uh, that,
that he had written as a young man.
And in this new poem,
a paradise regained the story ends.
Uh,
the story ends before the crucifixion and
even takes place because for Milton in
this absolutely remarkable poem,
the crowning moment of Christian history
and the point at which lost paradise is
actually regained something that
we are of course all ourselves,
the beneficiaries of it has nothing
whatsoever to do with the sacrifice the
father sacrifice of the son.
And it has nothing to do
with a magnificent battle
for that matter between Satan
and the,
and the Messiah.
It's a moment mentioned rather briefly
in a couple of gospel accounts of the
life of Jesus.
The Gospel of Matthew and the gospel
of Luke narrate the story of Jesus's
fasting. This all happens
in a, in a, in a, in a few,
in a few verses in the New Testament,
the story of Jesus fasting for 40
days in the wilderness and the three
temptations to which Satan subjected,
uh,
Jesus of during that time.
Now in the gospel of the loop loop,
which is the version that
Milton follows most closely,
Satan tempts the sun three times.
He asked this under turn stones
into bread in order to free himself.
He asked this, uh, and of
course the son refuses.
He asks the Sun to accept all the
kingdoms of the world as Satan Zone gift.
The son refuses and he asks us under
prove his divinity by casting himself off
the pinnacle of the temple
and the son refuses.
And that pretty much is it three
temptations and three acts of resistance.
And it is this simple, but of course,
never, nothing is ever that simple,
but it's this more or less simple,
um,
resistance of temptation in paradise
regained that constitutes the very center
of Christian history. This is, uh,
this is an extraordinary and for me,
unbelievable way of,
of rethinking and reimagining,
um, Christian theology
and the story of, uh,
and the story of Christian history itself.
The very premise of this poem is
I think a transgressive one. It
utterly, uh, changing all of the emphases
in traditional Christian doctrine.
The focal point, of course in Milton's
poem isn't, isn't really theological.
It's not mystical or sacramental.
It's ethical.
It's not the magic or the mysticism of
the crucifixion or the resurrection that
that has anything to do with
the regaining of paradise.
Here it is a simple and entirely,
I think an miraculous action
of behaving ethically.
It's something that any of us could do.
And as I mentioned a minute ago,
this poem is all about returning and,
and repetition.
And the pro do evangelism is a text
to which the characters are themselves
continually returning.
But there's another text that is
repeated if you can believe it,
even more obsessive. Lee, uh,
then that in paradise regained,
and that's the scene in which Jesus
is baptized by John The baptist.
The scene of the baptism is
narrated. First. It happens
right at the beginning. Um,
line 29 of the first book.
This is page four,
83 in the Hughes and we have
to look at this passage. Um,
it's narrated first in book one,
line 29 and following,
and then it's repeated and referred to
and worried about at least four times
over the after that. Over the course
of, over the course of the poem,
this is what we first learned on him,
baptized heaven opened
and in likeness of a dove,
the spirit descended while the father's
voice from heaven pronounced him his
beloved son.
Now we of course read these,
what I take to be these relatively
simple and unimaginative lines.
And if anything,
I think we should be overwhelmed by
their exceptional straightforwardness.
It's almost impossible to understand
what it is about this baptismal
pronouncement that could
prove so troublesome and so
difficult, um, in the poem,
but no one in the poem. And
that includes, of course,
the son of God himself.
No one in the poem has anything even
close to a clear idea about what these
lines actually mean.
And this radical uncertainty at the
very heart of the poem involves the fact
that these incredibly important revelation
is the product merely of the father's
voice,
the father's voice.
We're no longer in the world of paradise
lost where man can commune directly
with angels.
And even with the son of God and with
some frequency and with w with a degree of
relative ease,
nowhere in paradise regained his divinity.
Actually present.
Dad Isn't palpable.
It's not indisputably there
in the world of this poem.
And all we have is the father's voice,
his pronouncements or in other words,
all we have is a text,
just like the text of scripture
or in fact it is the text of scripture.
And the father has left us with a
little tay, a trail of his precedence.
Um, uh, in the form of the
words of the Hebrew Bible.
And everyone in the poem is desperately
scrambling to interpret this verbal
trail. These words and all of
this is a way of saying that the,
that the universe of paradise
regained is essentially to my mind,
a secular one. Uh, the world.
And this is essentially the world that
Milton had introduced us to at the end of
paradise lost. And in this
secular world, all con,
all one can really do is read the text
and try to figure out what it means.
And this is all the Satan and the sun
are in a position to do in paradise
regained.
And I think this is what gives this poem.
It's powerfully modernist feel.
Um,
it says skeptical and uncertain as it
is possible for such a profoundly and
piously religious poem to be. If I'm,
if that oxymoronic statement makes,
makes any sense. Um, look,
look at how Satan reacts
to the pronouncement of God
at the baptism that we just
looked at the pronouncement,
that this is my beloved son.
Lines line 33
that heard the adversary,
who roving still about the world at
that assembly famed would not be last.
And with the voice divine
nine thunderstruck,
the exalted man to whom such high a test
was given a while surveyed with wonder.
Satan rushes to the congregation of
angels assembled at the River Jordan. Um,
because he wants to hear
as the other angels do,
to hear the highest test that God is
bestowing upon this man from Nazareth.
This nobody who was the
son of Joseph deemed.
And it says it's at his hearing
of this divine voice that Satan is
thunderstruck. Now fender struck is, this
is, this is a striking word here. It, it,
it bursts out of this passage as
a little metaphor. And you know,
we're taking whatever we can get here.
We take note of it because Milton has
given us so little by way of Poetic
Metaphor,
um,
in this severely restrained
literary world of Paradise regained.
We're grateful. And, and, and the word
thunder struck is in fact, so striking.
And so that Milton has used
it only one other time in,
in all of his poetry and it,
and it's clear here that Milton is
asking us to remember that earlier
occurrence.
So I'm going to ask you,
does anyone here remember where
else in Milton extra credit here?
Um, where else in Milton we have, we
have encountered the word thunderstruck.
Yeah.
Okay.
Uh,
you're no one in paradise regained
seems to have remembered the parent,
the appearance of the word either.
Um, and so you're in good company.
If we can't imagine the inhabitants of
the world of paradise regained having
been in a position to read paradise lost,
which is something I think that
Milton sometimes asks us to imagine,
although of course it's
preposterous. Um, uh, it's,
it's clear. I think that Milton is asking
us to remember that earlier occurrence.
Um, so I'm going to ask
you to turn to page three.
43 of paradise lost the Hughes Edition.
This is the climactic moment.
Oh, and actually I have, uh,
I've included this
handily on your handout.
This is the climactic moment in the
war in heaven at which the son of God
assumes the chariot of paternal deity,
you know,
gets in dad's car and proceeds to put
a decisive end to the battle with the
rebel angels.
This is what I'm Rapheal tells Adam,
the overthrown he raised and as a herd
of goats are timorous flock together.
Thronged drove them before him.
Thunderstruck pursued with terrors
and with theories to the bound.
And Crystal Wall of Heaven.
And it's at this terrible moment of being
thunderstruck by the awesome power of
the sun that the rebel angels
throw themselves headlong
down from the verge of,
uh,
down from the verge of heaven.
This is obviously an unbelievably
consequential moment.
This is the moment of the, of
Satan's fall. And I think there's,
there's got to be a point to Milton's
recycling repeating of this word,
this striking word from paradise
lost. Um, in the new poem,
Paradise regained.
I think he's signaling signaling some
kind of connection between the horrifying
moment of the sun's Vick from Satan's
perspective of the son's victory over the
fallen of the rebel angels in the
earlier poem and the Son's new victory,
or what's about to be his new victory
over Satan that begins at this moment,
century later,
centuries later at the son's baptism,
Milton alludes to that climactic moment
in paradise lost, but on some level,
this is an illusion that the
later poem paradise regained,
doesn't know what to do with.
And in fact never really does
anything explicit with Satan.
Is Thunder struck at the
baptism just as he was,
some thunder struck at the war in heaven,
but Satan himself is incapable.
And this is just in, in,
in genius on Milton's part.
He's incapable of understanding how
these two moments might be in any way
related.
Um,
I don't know what kind of television,
if, if any, you all watch.
Uh, but I do know that not
when I was an undergraduate,
but because we got such
terrible, um, reception in the,
in the days before cable.
But when I was a graduate student
and living off campus and I had cable
television,
I spent an inordinate amount of time
watching a soap opera is during the day.
It was a way not to write
my dissertation. And, um,
if you've spent as much time as I have
a watching thousands of hours of soap
operas, um, you know what it
means to be thunderstruck,
which is something I take it to be closely
related to being struck by lightning.
Um, there is, uh, at least
in the 70s and in the 80s,
there's a point in almost every soap
opera at least once every two or three
years in which someone is struck by
lightning and the consequences in variably
the same.
It's the condition of Amnesia and soap
operas obviously couldn't survive without
some recourse to the,
the Amnesia plot,
the lightening striking plot because it's
a way to keep all of the actors intact
but reconfigure the reconfigure and,
and spice up a lot of the plots because
the same actor gets to be someone
completely new,
uh,
because he has to develop an entirely new
life and new relationships with all of
the preexisting, uh, actors
and cast members. Um,
I think it's something very close to
Amnesia that Satan is struck with at this,
at this moment in paradise regained.
And it's as if Satan has at this very
moment repressed any memory of his first
having been thunder struck.
He has completely forgotten about the
son's role in the war in heaven. And I,
and I actually have to be
more specific than that. Um,
Satan is incapable of applying
to the current situation,
any memory of who it was,
who had beat him in the war in heaven.
He has repressed the
presence significance,
this significant for the presence
present moment of the sons,
the son of God's victory. And it's the
nature of this repression, I think,
which is at the very center of Paradise,
regained
the central advanced that this poem has
made over a paradise lost is its refusal
to represent traditional epic action.
There's, there's no big battle here.
There's no war, there's no a huge
fight in which the woman's seed,
Christ bruises Satan's head.
There's really actually
no overt action at all.
The hero quite simply does nothing.
And he just keeps saying no.
And, and, and whatever action this,
this text presents to us
is clearly psychological.
And the psychological problem that
I think overwhelms all of the,
all of the characters in paradise regained
is the simple fact that they cannot
manage for the life of
them to relate the cur,
the current story that they're inhabiting
to the events of Paradise lost.
They have forgotten paradise lost.
No. So let me, let me ask you
to think about the dramatic,
the dramatic situation of this poem.
Satan knows perfectly well that God has
prophesied that one of his sons will
rise up one day and destroy him,
and he's very,
he knows that this is going to
happen and he's very clear about the,
the certainty of the prophecy from Genesis
Three 15 and Satan even knows that it
is this man named Jesus
who's being baptized now,
who will one day destroy him and who
will one day would be responsible for
bruising his head.
But Satan seems for some reason to have
no way of knowing that the son of God
who will at some point in the
future be responsible for his doom,
is the same son of God who had devastated
all of the rebel angels and Satan
himself. Of course, in the war in heaven,
Satan has no way of knowing that the
prophesied messiah that he's dealing with
now will turn out to be the son of God.
The first forgotten.
He has no way of knowing that the
Messiah will be that same absolutely
insufferable angel whom the
heavenly father had promoted so,
so arbitrarily.
And so Austin spaciously above all of
the other angels in Book Five of Paradise
lost that,
the traumatic scene of that
exultation on this day,
I have bee got my only son to
him. I'll need shall bow. Um, all,
all him who disobeys me.
Disobeys you remember all of those
thundering words of the, of the father.
Satan is incapable of relating that
traumatic scene to this traumatic scene,
the tractor to traumatic scene that he's
witnessing now. This is my beloved son.
Um, at the baptism,
look at what Satan says.
It's excruciating and it makes us squirm.
I think I'm at the top of page four 85.
This is book one,
line 89 seems trying.
Satan is trying to figure out what God
meant by his strange utterance at the
baptism. And you can see state and coming
so close to an understanding, but he's,
he can't seem to make the final logical
leap. And it's a leap of course,
that I think we all feel confident that
we would have made or been able to make.
[inaudible] 89 this is Satan.
His first big we know and sore have
felt he's remembering the war in heaven.
When his fierce thunder drove us to
the deep who this is we must learn.
So he's able to remember that sensation
of being thunderstruck and paradise lost,
but he can't connect
it with the thunderous,
properly proclamation of the sun at
the baptism. If there's a, it's a,
it's as if we have a failure of,
of the synaptic nerves and Satan's brain.
Um, and, and he, he can't
make what seems to be,
it's to us the obvious
cognitive link. Um, and,
and I think his inability to
make that link is, is surprising.
But we have to understand that Satan has
been traumatized and it says if the war
in heaven had produced in St and something
like a post dramatic stress disorder,
and the nature of this disorder is his,
well,
I think it's perfectly understandable.
And just in a simple psychological terms,
you'll remember that the original
motive for Satan's fall was the father's
exaltation of,
of his beloved son,
his now beloved son above
all of the other angels,
and that the resulting sibling rivalry,
uh,
was the spur for all of Satan's
later actions. The dilemma of,
of sibling rivalry is at the heart of,
of paradise regained as well.
But,
but sibling rivalry in this poem exists
solely as a phenomenon that has to be
repressed.
Satan simply cannot and will not make
the cognitive connection between the
rivalry he feels now to this
messiah character and the
one that he had felt that
primal originary rivalry that had
proven so devastating and paradise lost.
Now we may feel that we can understand
on psychological grounds there the reason
for Satan's inability to read the full
meaning of God's pronouncement at the
baptism.
But I think the true genius of Milton's
poem is the fact that the sun is just as
clueless as Satan.
The Sun has even less memory.
In fact,
then Satan about his former
activities in heaven,
the sun can't even begin to reconstruct
what had happened in paradise lost
because in assuming his earthly mantle,
he seems to have suffered
an a much greater and much
severe case of Amnesia than
the,
than Satan had.
And I think it's this image of Amnesia
or some kind of repression or have some
sort of pathological for getting that
may provide the most useful way of
thinking about the relation of
paradise regained to the earlier poem.
Paradise lost. Now let's think
about it from another perspective.
In writing paradise regained.
Milton has clearly had to repress
everything that had been spilled on
everything, but pretty much everything
that had been so liberating,
so revolutionary,
and so remarkable about paradise lost.
Now what might be,
it might be tempting to argue,
and it of course has been argued that
Milton is just getting old and he's
getting tired. He's not up
to all those similes now. Um,
but Milton has severed from his verse,
all of that luxuriant ornamentation
for a deliberate and I think a very
important reason he's
purging is verse of its care.
Of what we now take to be
its characteristic beauty
because he too like the
Satan and like the son is
struggling to forget paradise lost.
And I think there's an important sense
in which Milton is thinking of the
beautiful verse style of Paradise Lost
as something like a temptation in this
poem. And it's a temptation
that he, that he has to resist.
Look at the scene of the second
temptation in paradise regained.
This is a page 500 of the Hughes.
This is book two, line two 89.
Um,
the sun is beginning to get hungry
understandably after his 40 days in the
wilderness. And He, uh,
he enters a pleasant grove
where he encounters Satan
only in a bottom.
This is line two 89,
a book to only in a bottom saw a pleasant
grove with chant of tune. Full birds,
resounding loud vid there he bent his way,
determined there to rest at noon
and entered some and entered soon.
The shade,
high roofed and walks beneath and alleys
brown that opened in the midst of woody
seen nature's own work.
It seemed nature taught art
and to a superstitious I
the haunt of would gods and
would nymphs. I think this pretty
little landscape that we have here is,
is rather jarring in the
context of the reserved,
the sparing pleasures typically afforded
us in paradise regained and it's
drawing because this pleasant
grove remember, reminds us,
I think of in so many ways of the
garden of Eden from paradise lost.
Milton's description here is in fact
a tissue of Echos from book four of
Paradise lost where we're eating
opens onto a woody theater.
Just as this grove opens onto
a woody scene and, and, and,
and this grove appears,
seems to appear to possess,
would gods and would mimic as much as
diverse a paradise lost was filled with
the illusions to all of those classical
presences that Milton had cold from his,
his lifetime of reading
classical literature.
But here are the deities, a pagan
literature are branded as superstition.
Thus they relate earning
and all of those elements,
those aesthetic elements
that had made paradise lost,
so lovable,
so engaging.
And so when Tyson are now
branded as a temptation,
and it's as if the sun were being tempted
with something like the literature of
Paradise lost when he's presented
with this opportunity that he takes,
by the way, uh, to enter this
grove. And it's important,
it's important that the
son willingly enters a,
this pleasant grove that has been so
carefully fashioned of course, uh,
but by Satan and readers of this poem
rightly are always shocked. But by this,
by this moment, because this is
the son of God here after all.
And he's the very poor picture of virtue
and have perfect reason and he's made
this unbelievably stupid mistake.
This is like the mistake that red night
makes in the first Canto of the fairy
queen entering the would have error.
Um,
the beauty of paradise and by extension,
the beauty of paradise
lost is so tempting.
We could say that even the son
of God feels it's overwhelming.
Magnet magnet magnetic pole.
Milton I think is still though working
consciously here to renounce all of that
extraordinary poetic license
that he had taken in paradise.
Paradise lost.
And and this new poem explorers in more
depth and with more insight this the
merit,
the beauty of poetic renunciation
than any other poem ever has.
I'm convinced of that.
This is a poem all about denial and
repression and and its deepest and most
powerful meanings emerge. Not through our
sense I think of what the poem offers,
but our sense of what it's not offering
or what it won't permit itself to offer.
Now there's an obvious and explicit way
in which paradise regained is about this
kind of of negation or this
renunciation of paradise lost.
Paradise lost was about man's first
disobedience and the new poem Paradise
regained,
reverses that situation and treats another
man's unswerving obedience to God and
obedience so severe that at
times I think it strikes,
this is on on thinking or unreflective.
That's just the obvious way in which
paradise regained works to to negate or
undo the effects of paradise lost.
But there's another,
there's a more significant way in which
Milton's later poem attempts to forge
some kind of connection
with the earlier one.
Ma Milton and the new poem is acutely
aware of his already having written the
great epic paradise lost.
And in this,
in with this intense self consciousness,
it's an entirely new
neurotic burden for Milton.
Paradise regained,
takes up the problem that had proven
so difficult and so troubling to the,
to the younger Milton he needed,
takes it up once again.
But of course with a twist.
And this is the problem of
the poets career and it's
as if Milton can stand back
now and review the autobiographical
narrative he had written for himself as a
young man and take stock
in what he's accomplished.
So think of the basic situation that the
son of God finds himself in in paradise
regained even before they're remarkable
moment of God's pronouncement.
At the baptism,
Jesus had grown up with the knowledge
of his future role as the Messiah.
His mother had told him, his mom, Mary
had told him when he was a young boy, uh,
of what was to become what he was to be.
He had a very early age,
his sense of the important work that he
would perform at some future point in
time, but he didn't know exactly what
that work was going to look like.
And he didn't have a clue as to when he
was actually supposed to begin his work
and short the son of God before hand
before him a narrative of his career long
before he was able to imagine just how
that narrative was going to be fleshed
out.
Um,
and if this problem sounds
a little familiar to you,
that's of course because it is familiar.
This,
this is precisely the position that
the young Milton had found himself in.
He had declared at a very
early age that he was,
that he was chosen by God to write
a poem that his countryman would not
willingly let die. He was going to
be, um, England's literary messiah.
But,
but,
but that was years before he knew what
he was supposed to be writing about or
even when he was supposed to begin
writing. And as he says in paradise lost,
he was long and choosing
and beginning late.
And this is exactly the position that
the son of God finds himself in in
paradise regained.
Look at the top of page four 87 a book,
one line one 83.
This is the son of God,
trying to figure out what the father,
what the father must have
meant at the baptism.
Meanwhile,
the son of God,
who yet some days lodged in Bethesda
row where John Baptized musing and much
revolving in his breast,
how best the mighty work he
might begin of savior to mankind.
And which way first publish his God.
Like office.
Now mature. Now, if we
read this passage with,
with any sense at all,
any knowledge of its author,
I think that this moment in the life,
at this moment as a scene
from the life of Christ,
I dunno, it's, it's completely
absurd. This would, this is a,
it's a ridiculous situation.
You have Jesus thinking, hmm,
I'm supposed to be the savior of mankind.
Let me think. What should I do first?
I'm, I, I'm, I'm really
confused here. It's,
it's no one else has ever and would ever,
uh,
imagine such a scene of a,
of the kind of career anxiety,
um, in, in some sort of narrative
involving the son of God. It's,
it's laughable to think of the son of
God is undergoing something like a,
a career panic attack.
But this passage is very
different and it's an assumes,
I think an extraordinary
degree of significance when
it's placed in the context
of Milton's own ongoing
ruminations about his own career.
The son is asking himself
how he should publish,
how he should make public the God like
office into which he has now matured.
And I think it's impossible
not to hear in these lines.
The analogous concern that Milton had
himself revolved in his breast when he was
pondering when he should publish or bring
into print the fruits of what he knew
was his god like poetic talent.
So I want to conclude
with this suggestion.
The suggestion that Milton
has transposed the narrative.
This is only one of the myriad things
that he's doing in paradise regained.
He's transposed the narrative of his
own poetic of development onto the new
narrative of the sons,
the development of the sun,
sense of his own identity.
And, and by saying this,
I don't want to suggest that all paradise
regained his is an autobiographical
poem. I'm convinced of course, that
it is an autobiographical poem,
but it is first and foremost,
I think a meditation on the
problem of autobiography.
Milton is in the amazingly
peculiar position of having,
of having written his autobiography long
before he'd actually lived the bulk of
his life. That's what all those
career narratives were doing, um,
that he had penned in the,
in the early 1640s.
How do you actually live a life,
the end of which you already know.
What's the relation of, uh, of the, uh,
what's the relation of the anticipated
life narrative to the actual experience
of living?
These are of course,
the questions that play Gaddam and eve
in the last books of paradise lost as
they, as they learned the, the
future history of their descendants,
but still have to go about the
business of, of living their lives.
And these are clearly questions that get
to the very heart of Milton's relation
to the prophecy of his own poetic talent.
And they're questions that we will
begin to, that we'll begin to approach
that we will continue,
um,
throughout this week as we approached
the problem that Milton Confronts when he
writes paradise regained.
Um, and that's this question.
What does it mean?
What does it mean after all to write a
sequel to the poem that after times will
not willingly let die? Okay. Um,
I'm going to end there. I'm
going to ask you to, uh,
make sure you will have read all of
paradise regained, um, for Wednesday.
Okay.